i think there's
a real opportunity for machine learning
to empower the individual
against the list of the powerful players
as i said in the beginning here it's
been mostly the other way around so far
that the big players have the ai
and then they tell people this is the
truth
this is how it is but it can just as
well
go the other way around and when the
internet was born actually a lot of
people had this hope that maybe
this will be a great thing for democracy
make it easier to find out about things
and maybe machine learning and things
like this can uh can
actually help again and i have to say i
think it's impo it's more important than
ever
now because this is very linked also to
the whole
future of life as we discussed earlier
right we're getting this ever more
powerful attack you know
it's frank it's pretty clear if you look
on the one or two generation
three generation time scale that there
are only two ways this can end
geopolitically
yeah either ends great for all humanity
or ends terribly for all of us
there's there's really no in between it
and
we're so stuck in and because you know
technology knows no borders
and you can't have people fighting
when the weapons just keep getting ever
more powerful
uh indefinitely eventually
lux the luck runs out and and you know
right like right now we have i love
america
but the fact of the matter is
what's good for america is not opposites
in the long term to what's good for
other countries it it would be if this
was some sort of
zero-sum game like it was thousands of
years ago
when the only way one country could get
more resources
was to take land from other countries
because that was basically the resource
right you look at the map of europe some
countries kept getting bigger and
smaller
endless wars but then since
1945 there hasn't been any war in
western europe and they all got way
richer
because of tech so the optimistic
outcome is
that the big winner in this century is
going to be america and china
and russia and everybody else because
technology just makes us all
healthier and wealthier and we just find
some way of
keeping the peace on this planet but i
think
unfortunately there are some pretty
powerful forces right now that are
pushing in exactly the opposite
direction and trying to demonize other
countries
which just makes it more likely that
this ever more powerful tech
we're building is gonna use disastrous
ways
yeah for aggression versus cooperation
that kind of thing
you